also breaking right now there is the
partial closer of the 215 beltway near
mccarran airport metro police right now
saying that it's investigating a murder
in the eastbound lanes at warm springs
of course traffic becoming a big issue
there hector mejia joining us now live
near the scene of that investigation
hector what's the latest
well just in the last half hour police
increased their perimeter the 215
southern beltway all eastbound lanes now
closed starting at las vegas boulevard
no more access to the airport connector
from the 215 eastbound metro police
confirmed this is a homicide
investigation on the beltway and here's
what we know so far one victim dead on
the scene another was rushed to the
hospital at this hour no word about any
arrests so all eastbound lanes again of
the 215 closed now starting at las vegas
boulevard on our way here we saw the
investigators walking on the highway as
they searched for potential evidence and
that's the reason why the highway is
shut down this is where we expect to get
an update from metro police meanwhile
nhp expects this closure to last several
more hours so you will need a detour if
the 215 is part of your commute so let's
send it back over to nate tannenbaum
who's standing who's standing by with
the latest and a detour for you this
morning nate you got it thanks so much
hector so now the rest of the freeway
system on your monday is not bad that's
the south 15 getting crowded lanes are
open big squeeze you know about that by
now but let's head on down here it looks
like they're also trying to shut down
part of northbound i-15 i don't know if
that's correct but we do know that the
eastbound 215 beltway is shut down at
warm springs this uh whatever was
happened about 2 30 this morning so a
different view bottom line how do you
get around it for a while they were
diverting you off at the airport
connector but as hector said that has
now been pushed further back so you got
to get off the 215 at las vegas
boulevard we're suggesting you go up to
sunset it's kind of a long ride over to
eastern but it shouldn't be too bad
eastbound then you take eastern all the
way down to windmill kind of a long
workaround but you can get there
meanwhile there is another crash in the
southwest near the 215. this is actually
on durango south of the 215. so north of
the 215 on durango that's where the ikea
is at sunset but this crash is past the
215 southbound taking up the right lane
there so these are the folks who are
headed for the 215 from further south it
is the southbound lanes that are a
little bit of a mess lots going on on
the freeways lots going on with the
weather too so let's get an update from
sherry